the Academy award-winning actor and
starring in Paramount Networks
Yellowstone that premieres next
Wednesday at 9:00 Eastern Time thrilled
to have Kevin Costner back here on the
show how are you sir I'm good really
good and you know we were just watching
you putt a little bit right there
everybody was hoping that you'd get down
like Roy McAvoy and putt like back in
the day how how often do you get Roy
McAvoy thrown your your way when you're
out and about Kevin you mean you mean
just somebody calling my name is people
just when they bring up part of your
filmography to you well I tell you what
I can walk around sometimes and it's
like it's like hey crash you know it's
it's Roy it's like hey idiot and I'm
still turning there somebody says hey
I'll turn it Billy Chapel it feels like
the baseball movies or the ones where
the guys will call out to me is that
right yeah yeah and I am a bit recently
it's been happening guys who come up and
they're just about to shake my hand
they'll say you're the one that killed
my friend you know an open range when I
hit that guy right in the forehead sure
to get it started I'm thinking I have to
slow down with everybody you know I got
to figure out who I am I have it from
your filmography of people hit you yeah
and I kind of happiest in a way about
that you know because kind of a common
question a lot of times is you know what
favorite movie what's the favorite movie
and yes and UK it's difficult to answer
that but where I actually find myself is
the reality that I'm happiest is that
there's about 12 movies people will
mention and I don't know what's gonna
come out of their mouths and it could be
water rolled and it could be the postman
it's gonna be fill the dreams it's gonna
be dances it's gonna be JFK it's gonna
be those things but I don't know where
it's gonna come from and at the end of
the day I think you know that's good
that it's not one movie that was made
for different times that feels that
feels good to me so which of the
baseball movies do you hear about the
most if you had to split it between Bull
Durham and fielder Bob Bull Durham the
always amazing the most I've used as a
phrase already from Bull Durham just in
the past two weeks because of the amount
of strikeouts there have been in Major
League Baseball this year April was the
first month in the history of Major
League Baseball where there are more
strikeouts than hits
and we're seeing too many guys striking
out this year because everybody's
swinging for the fences exit velocity
and the line I keep using is about how
strikeouts are not only fascist they're
they're boring so I've used you I've
used your line quite yeah yeah you know
you know you do see trends you know and
in baseball I don't know when that trend
started maybe it was watching Justin
Vijaya or somebody I'm not sure but I
remember early baseball just meet the
ball just meet the ball you know what I
mean you don't just meet the ball and
and you see the way guys swing now they
just come out of their shoes I mean you
look at Justin so you need to go right
through the major league it's not just
meet the ball it sounds like well it's a
swing just as hard as you can that's
what it looks like to me that's been
like about a 20 year trend in my mind
exit velocity all these terms that you
hear that are being used
I didn't yeah that is just that I keep
thinking of like an old baseball men
like Crash Davis what he would think
about guys you just want to come up and
they think they're gonna major the
leagues because they've got a quick bat
and the ball shoots off the bat yeah and
I honestly maybe that's why people were
talking to Ron about this guy that was a
real good guy there's you know yeah
Shelton and then it was a guy that he
actually played with or somebody that
knew about that like led the the miners
and triple in and in the minor leagues
and let him in the home runs RBIs a
batting average and he it did it like
five years of row in a row and he
couldn't get into the big leagues but he
was sitting behind Brooks on the
Baltimore organization and you know
that's a long time ago those guys just
sat back they're like insurance and now
players are just brought up brought up
brought up and so many players you know
didn't make it back in those 60s
mhm yeah I mean and I think it was also
as didn't we bring what something up to
Brockman lately about there was a crash
Davis type player who I think in in the
NBA where he led the the d-league in
three-pointers like he led they
history of the minor leagues and three
orders and got his shot with the Lakers
at the very end of last season that
we're all writing his name and roii MVP
well Shelton had it so right with that
thing it kind of the you know baseball
you know you know you can't love
baseball unless you're into the
vulgarity and I you know and everything
but there's that poetry too that always
is something and Shelton found it the
most when you read it and and and maybe
most people that watch Bull Durham it's
a it's a it's a thing that doesn't
affect him the way it affected me when I
knew when I when he was at the end of
his career he decided to go hit that
homerun in obscurity because it was a
record he still wanted mm-hmm you know
and I mean it's not one he could ever
sit at the bar with guys who were in the
big leagues he said well I hit the most
summit he would never say it I'll I
wasn't that kind of guy on the other end
it was a record he knew was was average
was whatever it was but there was
something in him and his character that
he was that close that he went and
roomed with an eighteen year old so that
he would hit that last one did it in
obscurity and then went back to a knee
and it was over for him and there was
this weird kind of heroic dignity in
that thing not what a record he would
ever talk about but one he wanted at
that point Kevin Costner here in the
Rich Eisen show have you ever talked
about finding out where Bull Durham is
today where to find out where crash
Davis is today no but I know Ronnie I
know Ronnie is going on the thirty year
anniversary to Bull Durham on the 15th
and at the stadium and you know there's
a real place for him and obviously I
just from me but he's going back there
and that movies really you know stood a
test of time right and tin cup was also
with you in Ranchi yeah I mean he's I
mean he's the guy that understands that
that it isn't always about the wind you
know I mean he finds the heroism in in
just being who you are the character I
mean that's the greatest 12 in history
that's the that's the honor I love it
and I don't know if you're aware of this
as well but the Cleveland Browns have
had multiple first-round draft choices
twice since trout had it figured out for
them Adam going away
I did and you know I mean think about
that making a movie about the draft but
I thought we did you damn straight you
did I thought we did well you know I I
have a small role in that film
and one of my favorite stories of my
entire career was shooting that the day
after the first round of the draft and
Radio City Music Hall and I would just I
just come off of like a six hour mmm
night the night before and I had another
five hour one before and I just figured
okay I know I have one page of dialogue
I'll just get to it about a half hour
before I have to yeah so this is my
level of professionalism bringing to an
all so Frank Langella who played the
owner of the Cleveland Browns he shows
up on set and says to me the first thing
he says to me would you like to run
through our lines I know I'm like oh no
and I had to just tell him can you give
me a minute
rod wayafter started to shrink well
looking and I did when I did perfect
world they asked then to to narrate that
you know my game my perfect game that's
right and he came into the studio and
the director is in him Vin Scully and
he's on mister together and this is kind
of our movie here and any any stand of
them line and he goes in here's our some
of our lines if he could say something
you sly this is kinda thing cuz well
could you just show me the film and he
goes yeah well let me look at it he goes
let me see the film I'm gonna be it so
he kind of played like about six minutes
of it and Scully washed it and he goes
and then you can you do that he goes
well why don't you just let me take a
shot at this and so and so he he heard a
few things that the guy said and then he
started saying that stuff that's in the
movie just although she said yeah he's
just like it's like a songbird any and
it got all the way to it and any any guy
so it was like I I like that I was like
the Aaron my arm is setting up and then
the director said oh yeah and he goes
well well you do you want to
run it again and Vince as did we need to
and do we know to and and he said well
maybe maybe something well you know come
of it and Vince said alright alright
let's do that again
it was it was his prerogative to do that
sure and then who he is he just goes and
Billy chow you know and it's like and he
did something at to it and so we the
director what turned out was right on
this level but really what he what he
did there you know and I have it forever
right you do I have it forever and I got
a chance actually to do a speech for him
on his last day well you were kind
enough to call into the show a couple of
days after um seed or you were part in
problem see I think out maybe I'll
Michaels was but you spoke at his
farewell yeah interesting
yeah let's it was it was it was it was a
big moment he I got the word he said
look I'd like to have sandy Kirk and
Kevin and I immediately started running
for the Equis I thought there's got to
be a hundred people who need to be on
this field because no I want heavy and
he call me Kathy and I was like you know
I mean ballplayers always put a why on
your name they're the one guys that can
do it yeah and he just did that to me
and he goes no I want he because there's
something else about him and so it was
just gonna be us three Kirk couldn't be
there and eventually they evolved some
politician spoke but when I got up I
found what I wanted to say I don't know
if you got to see it yeah I found what I
wanted to say about him I kind of was
thinking about everybody who felt
something about him I felt like I was
like talking for them when I was talking
about him well you nailed it and I want
to take a break come back in 60 seconds
we'll talk about Yellowstone okay and
and and so much more with Kevin Costner
back in 60 seconds on the Rich Eisen
show
okay welcome back Kevin Costner's still
hanging with us here Yellowstone
premiering on paramount Network next
Wednesday at 9:00 Eastern Time
if I had two scripts on the desk
okay and you are being pitched as I'm
sure you always do for what your next
project is I have two scripts on the
desk you have no idea if the scripts are
any good but I have two scripts one of
the script as you throwing a ball or
catching a ball or talking about a ball
and the other one has you riding a horse
which one do you pick up first well I'm
gonna make one distinction sure if that
baseball ones indoors I'm going outdoors
if it's outdoors now I have a real tough
pick okay so you're okay you're doing a
okay so cuz draft day was indoors and I
guess you know what I'm saying I'm
saying I'm a recess guy I wasn't an
academic I love recess I love when the
bell went off because I wasn't ever make
it letting my mind go but if I had to
choose between a baseball movie and a
Western I would do the Western why is
that because I've got three baseball
movies and I never gonna have enough
westerns for me huh so when did when did
you first fall in love with the Western
which was the Western I think I was I
was seven years old I was I was at the
Cinerama Dome my feet were like right
out here I went to a little boy's
birthday party back in the 60s and it
was how the west was won and I looked up
and there was an overture playing it's a
four-hour movie so you can see it marked
me in a lot of ways all my movies are
real long too and I sat through that
movie all the kids were dinking around i
sat through the intermission because I
didn't want to miss a thing when the
intermission was over it watched it all
the first image was Jimmy Stewart and
this canoe going across this lake that
was like this it was like your table
that wasn't a ripple and he was dressed
in skins and he and as a camera moved
and he saw where he was going there was
these exotic people that he was going to
talk to you on his Beach and they were
dressed with the feathers and they were
just it was and I thought I was marked
at that moment that was what I wanted to
do I wanted to know who those people
were
I want
that kind of life for myself and I
literally built three canoes in my life
up until I was 18 I went down some of
the rivers at Lewis and Clark you know
you know when went down and that was for
whatever reason that the idea of America
how big it was what it was would
literally the Garden of Eden to be
honest before there was this giant
movement across the continent and
Yellowstone is a more modern day
tell me Yellowstone is a different is a
different look it's a it's a it's a it's
a it's a like why didn't I think about
it look of course that's what ranching
is you know what I mean it's it's it's
not an it it's not a modern look at
ranching it's a look at modern ranching
which is the trappings are when I think
of for instance like Cirque du Soleil
one of the things I think about is like
you know they reinvented the circus you
know I mean it and and because and they
have the clowns the freaks the juggling
their roots of what the circus are in
Cirque de Soleil are are there and I
think that's the beauty of Cirque du
Soleil they never lost the roots of what
the circus is about but they reinvented
it and and ranching is still pretty much
the same as it's ever been for the last
200 years here but the differences are
what ATVs and some helicopters if you're
have a giant spread condos golf courses
well people that's that's that's the
threat you mean we basically took it
from indigenous people an interesting
thing is the rich people that the people
that held these big land tracts for the
last hundred and fifty years they're
losing their land now to just in their
death tax inheritance these giant
ranches are gonna that are beautiful
that in a way keep the land you know in
a way pristine not going to be filled
with condos and stuff those are breaking
up the children simply can't afford the
taxes and so if you overlay that
urbanization lawyers the environmental
protection agencies are sure and dealing
with indigenous people the Native
American issues
right now Yellowstone it rolls that all
together it is quite good I saw it last
night it's really good and it's next
Wednesday is when it debuts at 9:00
Eastern Time on paramount Network you
play the role of John Dutton who is the
patriarch of the powerful family and
who's controlling that largest
continuous ranch in the u.s. that is all
these modern infringement upon it yeah
you know I've got the dysfunctional
family to go with it you know you don't
you're not gonna have any drama without
it but you know it's it's a it works and
it's in it in a way that you know and in
its listen there's a it's a it's a I
like it you know I have I set my trailer
up my little stream there's a base camp
where most of all the other trailers are
on the food and I said just put my
trailer over here by this stream I come
to work I just start a fire I wait I go
to work I come back and it's at night if
we're working and pretty soon there's
six seven people just around the fire
talking it's it's a pretty good life
well and and I look forward to seeing
Yellowstone here at 9:00 Eastern Time
it's funny Kevin when we had our first
segment you were talking about all the
movies that you get maybe thrown at you
one one film you did not mention the
untouchables which is another film for
me that is a remote drop where I see it
on TV I just have to drop the remote no
matter where I am in the film do you
have a Sean Connery story you can share
I remember one time you know I was with
Sean it was in Chicago and and as I was
kind of talking to him there there's
this really this girl was really trying
to get my attention she was cute and I
didn't I didn't want to rush over there
because Sean told me a story one time of
a girl sitting next to him that kept
tapping him tapping him and he knew she
was there he was he knew his going to
get to her but he kept up his
conversation kept it up finally tap and
finally when this dumb conversation was
over and he really wanted to see what
the bird was all about he looked over
there and her cigarette was just now
hanging out of her mouth he was she was
trying to give him what he thought was a
note and it was a lighter and so she
looked pretty pathetic so I had that
story on my mind when I was with him and
some girl was trying to get my attention
like looking over looking over and
finally I'm kind of done with him and I
think well stroll over and see what she
really wants like I did I walked as she
was behind the ribbon I got really close
to her I said yeah and she goes could
you get me Shawn's like I said yeah
biggest are the biggest oh yeah and and
the real deal and you know you know
really honest I mean he well he was
upset on Untouchables he was set because
he thought somebody had treated him
wrong in production was gonna cost him
money and money was important to him how
it worked and that kind of thing and he
it was really it was really angry was in
a bar and he called me only goes mr.
Nash he'd called meanness mr. Nash yeah
and I go yeah and and I go what he goes
gonna sit out here with me and I would
and I sat down and he had this piece of
paper at like a yellow pad just like
what you have yeah any and he said you
remember this do you remember that and
it was like stuff that was right and
stuff that was wrong and and I mean I
said I remember that I remember that and
yeah I remember that and he got thank
you and he went and tore this guy's head
off he just needed to be sure he needed
to be sure that that he wasn't going to
be wrong all facts confirmed McKenna
it didn't want to kind of you know put
boy then it was you know then then it
was lit then it was on Lookout yeah and
I admired him for that and you know Burt
Lancaster is well I mean yeah Field of
Dreams yeah and you know Burt Burt when
when he was doing that scene that it was
so beautiful behind the desk you wrap
your arms around second they should look
up at that sky he was a lot with his
hands he was a lot with his hands and
you know and a and and you know and he
told me all the studios were scared of
me they're scared of me
and I think of me and Douglas there's
scared of me hurt Chuck yeah and I asked
him this I asked him the scene about the
Kentucky and you know where he runs
across the water if you ever saw that
and you saw that yeah
because you saw I said yeah because you
know how did said no I guess I'll tell
you what I did he said I started when I
had to end and I ran back as quick as I
could
and he said and I wanted to see and I
said when I start running back load the
gun I need to know how long it's gonna
take you and so he said I did and that
was a mark and that's where I hadn't put
the camera so now then they call action
I'm running this way and just about the
time he got the gun loaded I jumped and
I had him down
it was perfect and and I just I just
listened to him and they just looked at
me goes they were scared of me they were
all fantastic it was it was a he was a
good thing anyway
he was also generous to people you know
like I said them you know and and I said
you know that that fight you had with
Matthau and he goes you saw that and I
go yeah that's a really good thing and
you know we think of Matthau is that
great comic that kind of hound dog you
know download newspapers that's bad he
was a badass in in Kentucky and and I he
says I talked to him about how the whip
went out and it was the way he was
losing the fight and the girl rolls like
wagon over the wheel and he he's just
he's been beaten lancaster up beaten him
up and now he throws his whip and it's a
kind of a coup to grow on the girl who's
like lancaster is on a wagon she sees it
she plucks a horse and it moves over the
thing and Matthau for the circus and
then the music starts in lancaster gets
to win the fight and that's kind of why
I like the movies you saw that I'm like
well I mean you've directed the film as
well yeah this has been always great
chatting with you my last one for you is
what is your remote drop movie I don't
know how much TV i watch your remote
drop movie where you're watching TV if
you do have the time and you pass a
movie what is Kevin Costner's you know I
watch Cool Hand Luke that's it no matter
where you picked i watch it yeah yeah
i'll watch it it was it's what what
about Cool Hand Luke makes that your
remote drop movie I don't know it was a
perfect movie for him there was
perfect movie for anybody watch and I
you know I you know the the crash Davis
doesn't always win either just in Cup
and either did Cool Hand Luke and you
somehow in your heart even though you
want good endings people want happy
endings sometimes what we realize if we
can't get the happy ending the ending we
have to get is the one that we have to
understand why it ended the way it did
and when we really understand something
the way it's supposed to be we have a
easier way of accepting it and go that's
the way it had to be the and the and and
and that's the poetry and those that are
always trying to make we like a good
ending I like it just as much as anybody
else but sometimes when I feel the power
of a movie and it doesn't end the way I
want if if the level of understanding
has been built into it I accept it in it
and it becomes something I loved check
out paramount networks Yellowstone
starring you Kevin Costner Wednesday
June 20th for those without the calendar
at 9:00 p.m. Eastern Time
you are welcome here anytime you thanks
thanks for having appreciate thanks for
coming here that's Kevin Costner here on
the Rich Eisen show the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience